>> John S.: A LONG SHOT BY CECI,
OFF OF THE POST AND IT WAS
NOT TO COMMIT TO CONNOR
McDAVID.
CUTTING THROUGH THE M LAST GAME.
HERE NOW, CONNOR McDAVID, YOU
SEE HOW MUCH ROOM HE HAS GOT.
PUCK AND HE GOT IT, COVERED IT
TIPPED, REBOUND HAS AND
McDAVID IS STOPPED BY MARTIN
THT
STICKSIDE ON MARTIN.ED BY
KOSKINEN AND THEN THAT PASS FOR
THE GOAL AND, SOMEHOW, IT STAYED
TO GET TO.
TIPPED IT UP, OFF THE
DRAISAITL A STEAL AND LEON
DRAISAITL A QUICK SHOT!
MARTIN FLASHING OUTETTING ENOUG.
ABLE TO TRAP
COULD SEE HIM
AWKWARDLY GOING AFTER IT WITH
HIS E EOPKINS ON THE BACKHAND
WHO HAD GOTTEN A SECOND ATTEMPT
THIS IS MARTIN HE SENT MOTTE OFO
GO BACK, A LOT OFHE GOAL, THEY E
PERIOD ENDED.
A WILD FLURR
PUCK, CHAISSON AGAIN!
DIVING OUT, KOSKINEN!
>> John G.: KOSKINEN, GOOD SAVE
THE OILERS WITH LIFE, RIGHT BACE
FLEURY OF
CHANCES, IT
PENALTY IS OVER.
EKMAN-LARSSON OUT OF AFTER THATY
HAD EXPIRED LEON DRAISAITL GOT
IT PAST IS QUINN WITHOUT OUT THR
THREE MINUTES AS THE PANTHERS
CONTROLLED I TAKING A
FEED, CUTS IN.
STOPPED THERE BYPETTERSSON, BACD
THE WRONG WAY THERE.
N GOAL AND STOPPED BY
KOSKINEN, REBOUND THERE ANDDRAIA
GREAT TOE SAVE McDAVID AND SOMEO
KOSKINEN, EDMONTON RALLYING FROM
2-0 DOWN AFTER TWO TO